[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to my tomes of
terror book review series
so i came across this little novel here
which came out in i believe february of
2022 this is called the adirondack witch
by patrick
ruman or royman not really sure how to
pronounce that so
i apologize i tried to like get both in
there uh but yeah so i came across this
as i come across a lot of my
my things my books that i review during
a kind of random scroll through my
kindle unlimited recommendations
and this one caught my attention because
i love witches okay and i kind of feel
like there's not enough books about them
particularly like kind of old school
like hag type witches because i love
that kind of [ __ ]
so i said all right i'll uh i'll check
that out and jump right into it
now i will say i enjoyed this overall uh
i thought it was going to be like a
little bit more
of an urban legend kind of vibe it does
i don't know i wanna it does have like a
little bit of that but it's kind of like
a different sort of thing going on
um so it was like had a lot of creepy
imagery and like if you're into real
like kind of creepy lost in the woods
type vibes with sort of a witch kind of
uh monster happening in it then it's a
pretty solid read but i did have a
couple issues with it uh that i'll get
into in a little bit
um to get into some of these issues
though i'm going to have to do like some
spoilers because otherwise it's going to
be really hard to talk about so if you
want to read this
obviously go read it now before
listening to this because i might spoil
some stuff for you that you don't want
spoiled as i said if you have a kindle
unlimited subscription then you can read
it for free or obviously you can buy the
paperback if you would rather do that
so the story kind of centers around uh
the main character whose name is hank
i can't remember if he had a last name
or if anybody uh said what his last name
was now at the beginning of the story he
seems to be sort of like going back and
forth like reminiscing about the time
that he met his wife mary this beautiful
woman that he was very very much in love
with and he's basically like he met her
i guess she was like a co-worker but she
worked in like a different part of the
company so he didn't like know what she
looked like or anything but so
accidentally she sent there was like a
work email like a group email or
something like that and she accidentally
replied to him alone instead of replying
to everybody and they got to talking and
then like eventually met up in person
later and it was sort of like love at
first sight type of thing so you know
they got married blah blah now the story
doesn't really go too much into their
courtship or their marriage or anything
like that too much um but it's just kind
of like enough to sketch in the details
about it
now not too long after this
you discover that mary has passed away
recently like in the past three to six
months i want to say
uh ostensibly from cancer although you
don't find that out until probably like
halfway through the book when he tells
somebody else
now hank is obviously very very
distraught about this as he loved her
very much
and he's really not doing too well like
he's going on a downward spiral type
situation like he basically just walks
off his job he starts drinking a lot and
just kind of like laying around on his
couch kind of wallowing in self-pity
type of thing
now his mom and his sister are really
worried about him as you would be and
they keep kind of dropping by his house
unannounced to sort of like nag him a
little bit to get like his [ __ ] back
together but he's like not really having
it and he's just kind of like don't they
understand i need like more time and
stuff like that and he's just not ready
to move on from his wife yet now
thankfully uh he has a couple of good
buddies named scott and charlie
and they seem to be fine with letting
him recover at his own pace you know
they're pretty chill and they just kind
of let him do what he's going to do
now not too long into the story for
whatever reason hank decides that he's
going to or he needs to really take a
hiking trip into the adirondacks
uh and this he feels like this will help
him clear his head and sort of like get
over his wife's death now apparently um
he and his wife mary had talked about
taking a trip like this like when she
was still alive
and so he feels like this is something
that he has to do like to get a sense of
closure i guess
now the setup here uh if you're a big
horror fan as i am
will sound a little bit familiar to you
because it is kind of similar
to the premise of the 2017 film which is
excellent called the ritual
and that was actually based on the novel
by adam neville which came out back in
2011. i've reviewed some other adam
neville books cunning folk and no one
gets out alive but i don't think i've
i haven't read that one so i haven't
reviewed that one but yeah that's the um
book that it's based on
so
know that going in this is kind of like
a similar setup to that this story goes
in like different directions but it does
have a similar premise to the ritual so
if you like that you might like this as
well
now hank's mom pretty much begs him
please don't go on the trip um you know
this is not going to be good people get
lost up there blah blah blah he says no
i'll be fine i'm not going alone my
friends scott and charlie are coming
with me
so for the first i want to say quarter
to third of the book we're following
hank scott and charlie as they're kind
of like getting ready to go on the trip
like they go to the you know the store
and like buy tents and like all the
stuff they'll need and [ __ ] like that
hank starts researching like which would
be the best mountains to climb because
he's you know a newbie and he's like i
don't want anything too strenuous blah
blah
now against his better judgment too he
also kind of becomes sort of fascinated
by
all these online news stories about all
the hikers who have died while they were
hiking in the adirondacks or have
disappeared altogether and have never
been found so he starts kind of like
getting into that going down that rabbit
hole as well
so then finally the day of the hike
arrives
and the trio start heading up the
mountain
now even though hank chose what he
thought was one of the easiest climbs
he's kind of like a little bit out of
shape and he spent the last few months
like drinking and [ __ ] like that so it's
probably not helping his you know
physical fitness any uh so the hike is
much harder than he anticipated uh
especially because he's carrying this
big tent on his back it's like a large
several person tent now he kind of gives
it back and forth like scott charlie and
him like you know take turns carrying it
but it's still like a really long way
and it's really strenuous but he gets
cheered up a little bit when he actually
runs into and befriends sort of like two
little knots or groups of people that
are also going up to the same summit
so the first group is like an older
couple uh like retire retirement age
named george and eve
and with them is this young woman i
guess in her 20s or something like that
named jennifer and she was actually the
best friend of their deceased daughters
so they're actually doing the climb
for pretty much the same reason that
hank is doing it because they're like oh
our daughter loved this mountain and she
did this hike a bunch of times and we
wanted to like honor her memory or
whatever so they're doing that
um so then you also have there's this
other younger couple named jake and
jackie
and they tell hank look we live nearby
and we've done this climb like hundreds
of times it's one of our favorite ones
and everybody is nice except for jake
who's kind of an [ __ ] but you know
it's okay so they all decide oh we're
all gonna go up together and this will
be really cool he's made some new
friends or whatever
so they do that um but they actually
don't end up getting to the summit until
kind of like later in the afternoon and
they're all like looking at the view and
the view is beautiful and breathtaking
and everything like that but because
hank and the older couple to a lesser
extent are kind of like inexperienced
hikers or are not in as good a shape as
the younger people the climb took
probably like way longer than some of
the younger ones were anticipating
so they're basically like well we
obviously can't go all the way back down
the mountain in the dark because you
know there's no lights or anything like
that and we don't really have the
equipment or anything to do that
so they're like well we should probably
just camp up at the top of the mountain
and then we'll go down like first thing
in the morning and hank's like oh well i
have a tent so and all of us should fit
in it so you know everything's fine he
has some energy bars and they have water
and everything like that so everything's
gonna be super cool
problem is though that when they wake up
the following morning
it's still dark as in
the clocks or their cell phones say that
it's like seven or seven thirty in the
morning
and uh the sun is not visible matter of
fact uh neither are the moon and the
stars visible it's just basically this
enveloping
blackness you can still kind of see the
woods and [ __ ] like that like if you
shine your flashlight on your phone
around but
there's everything's just dark
uh even more weirdly than that they're
like kind of looking out over the valley
or whatever and they're like they see
what looks like
a village like an old school village
like with torches and stuff like all
around it they're like okay pretty sure
that wasn't there before and that's not
supposed to be there so what the [ __ ] is
going on why hasn't the sun come up what
is this village what the hell so there's
that
so obviously everybody's freaked out now
at first they don't really know what to
do and they're like well maybe we could
just like wait around a little bit maybe
it's an eclipse or some freaky thing
like that it's like hell we don't know
so it's like well let's just wait around
up here for a bit and then you know
we'll see if the sun comes up or
anything like that uh so it doesn't
and after that they're like okay well we
can't just sit here all day you know we
don't have any food or anything like
that other than a couple energy bars so
we're just gonna have to like try to get
the [ __ ] off this mountain in the dark
you know sadly so they try to hike back
down in this sort of eerie blackness
but they notice that i mean they have
flashlights on their phones and [ __ ] but
everything is different like the trail
isn't where it was on the way up
and also there seems to be kind of
something in the woods that maybe is
sort of like following them or watching
them they kind of hear like foot steps
like behind them every now and then but
they look and like nothing's there and
it's just like you know really creepy
now all along the way uh hank starts
having like when they have to stop in
camp and stuff starts having these weird
dreams about this kind of like really
horrifying like witch-like creature in
the woods
and he's also having sort of like dreams
or like flashes of memory
about his life with his wife mary
uh at which point like i said it seemed
like very very rosy at the beginning
like oh i loved her more than anything
and she was so beautiful and blah blah
but like you kind of as it goes along
and he has more memories you learned
that it wasn't really like as great as
he was making it seem like they were
actually kind of getting ready to
divorce like they hated each other and
all this other kind of stuff so you're
kind of doing that
so as i mentioned earlier uh the novel
does have a similar premise to the
ritual which if you haven't seen it is
about like four guys who they have a
friend that dies and they had been
wanting to go on this hiking trip and
blah blah and it's kind of like a folk
horror type situation so there's that um
this is also very obviously influenced
by the blair witch project uh something
which is actually referenced in the text
itself because
kank the main character is um like a big
horror movie fan and he like you know
pretty much straight up says oh like the
blair witch project blah blah blah
so there's that so it's kind of like
this whole people lost in the woods
there's a possibly real or maybe it's
not a real witch like kind of following
them around and you don't really see it
and it's kind of like in the shadows or
like out you know on in everyone's
peripheral vision and [ __ ] like that
now
i will say though and this is kind of
where the spoiler alert territory is
coming in
from very very early on in the story
even before hank goes on the hiking trip
you know that there's something else
going on here
unless you aren't reading the story very
closely or
are not really aware of horror tropes of
any way shape or form
you will very very quickly realize
that hank's two friends scott and
charlie
do not exist that they are just figments
of his imagination
uh this is actually telegraphed pretty
clearly
by the fact that no one really interacts
with them or talks directly to them and
it's pretty obvious like the way it's
written
that
it's written in a way that makes it very
clear that you know people are talking
to him but it's like he wanted to make
it seem like they were talking to scott
and charlie but nobody really was and
it's like really obvious that they're
not so i mean i was maybe like 10 15
into the book and i was just like these
[ __ ] aren't real he's like imagining
these two guys i just i don't know why
it was so obvious but it was like really
obvious and i read like a bunch of other
reviews and pretty much everybody said
the exact same thing they're like 10 in
i was like yeah these dudes aren't real
so it's telegraphed very very clearly i
mean they do things like
you know even before they go on the
hiking trip like i said like they show
up show up at his house without knocking
like he's in the bathroom getting
dressed and one of them will pop into
the bathroom and he's like hey i didn't
hear you come in and stuff like that i'm
like these [ __ ] aren't real yeah and
they're not so uh so as soon as you've
figured that out uh like i said probably
only 10 15 percent of the way into the
novel you pretty much you know going
forward you're gonna distrust everything
that hank uh perceives and says because
now he's obviously an unreliable
narrator
and from this you can kind of
extrapolate what the twist at the end of
the story is going to be
now knowing this fact didn't really
dampen my enjoyment of this story too
much
um and the story didn't end up going
exactly the way that i thought it was
going to go like it did kind of surprise
me a couple of times but if if you're
kind of like
i don't know i kind of feel like it
readers might be disappointed um if they
thought like what was presumably
supposed to be this big revelation at
the end like oh my god this dudes
weren't real but
but it seemed like 99 of the reviews
that i read like they had figured that
out like in the first like 20-25 pages
um so like i said if you're if you're
attentive or seen like any
you know horror movies at all you will
kind of like know what's going on
um i also had a couple of like maybe
like smaller issues this wasn't really
that big a deal
but i mean there are a lot of characters
and so they're not really all that
fleshed out like some of them like i
guess eve is sort of fleshed out because
he kind of like talks to her more like
the older lady
but
i want to say too that three of the
characters names
start with jay
jake jackie and jennifer
and for a little while like when he
first met them i was like i kept
confusing like jackie and jennifer
because they were both young women and
they didn't really have any
i don't know they didn't really seem to
have anything that made them distinct
from one another so i kept like melding
them together in my mind so it was like
kind of confusing until like i sorted it
out there was also this one thing this
was really weird this is one thing that
kind of like
it was jarring and it kind of like took
me out of the story for a little bit
now
pretty much the entire book is told from
hank's perspective
but at one point like maybe three
quarters of the way through the story
something like that
we jump into george's
pov for some reason like inexplicably
this never happens for any other
character like we never get inside the
heads of any other character and i'm not
entirely entirely sure like why this
scene in particular
had to be from george's point of view
like it was just really weird and it
wasn't even like its own chapter it was
like a section within another chapter
and it was just like a few paragraphs
and i was just kind of like okay well
that seemed random like because the
whole other thing was like from hank's
point of view unless it was the kind of
thing where hank was seeing things from
george but i don't know it was like
really strange but i was just kind of
like that if it had happened like more
than once it wouldn't have been so
jarring but because it just happened
that one time i was like okay why do we
do that i mean it didn't really
interrupt the narrative like you kind of
got a little bit of perspective on
something but it just seemed weird that
it was just like that one time i think i
guess is what the big deal was all
together though um i did actually have a
good time with this book i read it
really quick um it moves along pretty
quick it's pretty fast paced um even
though i guessed like a lot of the stuff
that was gonna happen
it was still pretty entertaining kind of
just going along for the ride
and uh you know the imagery of the witch
was actually really creepy and some of
the weird [ __ ] that happened to them in
the woods like i really liked
the build up and like the imagery and
[ __ ] like that was like really eerie i
liked that um there was just enough
ambiguity to kind of like keep it
interesting and like keep me reading
even though i had figured some stuff out
ahead of time as i said i kind of wish
that hank's you know unreliable narrator
status wasn't so
glaringly obvious like from pretty much
the beginning of the story
but um as i said the story did actually
manage to surprise me a couple times i
wasn't sure exactly where it was going
even though i kind of got in the
ballpark um but yeah so if you like
things like the ritual or the blair
witch project and don't really expect
anything that's kind of like too
out there or like too outside of the
bounds of like some horror tropes that
you will probably recognize then it's a
pretty solid read if you like witches
and lost in the woods type stories and
stuff like that so you know if you've
read it or if it sounds interesting to
you then let me know in the comments and
that will do it for this tomes of terror
i will see you guys on the next one bye